president Trump predicts a quote very
big success when he meets with Kim
jong-un the highly anticipated summit
will be held June 12th in Singapore and
officials said the location is
convenient and both leaders security can
be ensured mr. Trump told Reuters during
the campaign he would quote have no
problem speaking to Kim his tone is
shifted dramatically in recent months
going from threats and insults to
gratitude if you look at North Korea
this guy this may I mean he's like a
maniac okay and you got to give him
credit how many young guys he was like
26 or 25 when his father died take over
these tough generals and all of a sudden
you know it's pretty amazing when you
think of it you look at North Korea
we're doing nothing there China should
solve that problem for us Korea best not
make any more threats to the United
States they will be met with fire and
fury like the world has never seen
Rocket Man is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime North Korea
is not to paradise
your grandfather envisioned it is a hell
that no person deserves Kim Jong hoon
was he really has been very open and I
think very honorable from everything
we're seeing
who really was excellent to these three
incredible people so the relationship is
good and hopefully I mean for all of us
for the world hopefully something very
good is going to happen so it seems no
more little rocket man one National
Security Council official says the
president will not make what she calls a
deal for a deal say